it is Game one of the NBA Finals as
we've been discussing in Toronto yes the
Raptors will host Game one against the
two-time defending world champion Golden
State Warriors on ABC and getting set to
call it alongside Mike Breen and Mark
Jackson once again is Jeff Van Gundy
back here on the Rich Eisen show how are
you Jeff how are you I'm doing I'm doing
great is by our count let's see if we're
accurate is this your 13th NBA Finals
you're calling on ABC and ESPN Jeff yeah
that's what BS ESPN people told me so I
really didn't I'm not I'm not big on
counting but yeah I've really been
fortunate I think it's Mike's 14 because
Mark was coach in a few years it's his
11th yeah that's right so it's your 13
that's so I guess it's it's kind of like
your bar mitzva broadcast Jeff in a way
up there in Toronto lucky 13 are you I
will open the floor right now I'm
watching what type of finals you think
this is going to be having seen Toronto
beat the Bucks four straight and
obviously the Warriors - Durant for at
least the first game perhaps longer what
do you see between these two teams Jeff
well I think it's gonna be I think
dramas got a great chance to win it with
or without Durant I think they have
three huge factors going in their favor
going into Game one home court advantage
the health of their team and it's not
just Iran its cousins it's a quad ala
and then also they have rhythm coming in
they've been challenged more in these
playoffs they're in a normal sort of
rest and play ratio versus Golden State
who's had so many days off in a row and
it's impossible to keep your rhythm as
an NBA team when you've been off as long
as Golden State has been now they have
the rest advantage but I think in Game
one they're going to face a challenge of
rhythm that I don't think will impact
Toronto
terms of what Nick nurse could be
crafting in the same way that he and his
staff were able to craft something for
Yanis what do you think that they are
most concerned about going into this
series and coming up with a plan best
they can to stop well I think you know
curry and Thompson put such pressure on
you and ways that most NBA players don't
in that obviously we know about their
great shooting but it's their movement
without the basketball how they are
relentless running to open spaces using
screens off the ball and so I think Nick
nurse and his staff number one decision
is how much switching do we want to do
off the ball people equate switching
with being the panacea to good defense
and it's not it may be easier at times
but it's not necessarily better I think
Nick nurse has to decide what's best for
his group do they do what they've done
all year or are the Warriors so good
that they have to do stuff dramatically
different I think you'll probably err on
doing what they've done all year and I'm
going to be interested to see how each
coaching decision impacts the next
coaching decision so if you're going to
switch more rich matchups meaning less
because the more you switch the more the
original matchup means nothing and I
think the one thing Toronto has going
for them is they're a highly defensive
oriented group who has terrific
individual defenders and they're gonna
have to play excellent one-on-one
defense very well I mean if you want to
talk about excellent one-on-one
defenders or excellent defenders
obviously you could start a conversation
but the entire NBA with Kawhi Leonard
what work where would you deploy him
Jeff Van Gundy if you were coaching this
Raptors team on on who would you place
Kawhi I would like him to be on a
draymond Green and that can hopefully
make the curry green pick-and-roll that
often leads to green getting
ball in space and having a four-on-three
type decision to make and he's
outstanding at that if you put Leonard
on green you can switch the pick and
roll and and Leonard can guard curries
effectively and then loudly so strong
and so tough that you know greens not
going to bully him you don't worry about
green rolling you into the post or
anything like that the one thing you
can't allow is green to catch the ball
in space with a numerical advantage and
how does Durant change this he comes
back and the right now is you and I are
talking it's been exactly three weeks
twenty-one days since he limped off the
court in Game five against the Rockets
and as we all know the Warriors haven't
lost since that night so how does he
change the equation he comes back based
on everything we've just said over the
last couple of minutes well I think it
all depends on where they are in the
series if and when he comes back I don't
believe necessarily that he'll be back
in this series I've had guys with calf
strings and it is a very difficult
injury to try to hurry back from you
know you can have a curry issue like a
dislocated finger or something like that
but you have your legs you know Durant
like this idea that he'll come back 70%
or 80% on a calf strain I'm not sure you
can do that so I think it depends on if
you can come back and if he can come
back where they are in the series when
he does come back I don't think you
bring to land back and bring him off the
bench you might be able to do that with
cousins you probably would do that with
cousins but Durant you know two
championships in two years and two
Finals MVPs and you want to re-sign him
I don't think you would bring him back
off the bench so I think these decisions
that Steve Kerr may well have at some
point in the series really really
challenging decisions because you're the
number one job is to give your team the
best chance you can to win but there are
other rama
ocation that go into those decision Jeff
Van Gundy here on the Rich Eisen show
and let's talk about the coaching aspect
of this here Jeff it seems as Steve Kerr
has reached a certain status that that
many coaches reach in the NBA that we
just think he just rolls the basketballs
out and his team wins championships I
guess that that that's some rarefied air
sometimes that you're able to do it
achieved what what does Kerr do that
keeps this engine going as well as it
has now four wins away from a third
straight championship what was it in
great coach in the NBA that wins
championships
their names are going to be attached to
Hall of Fame players you know Phil
Jackson and Michael Dillard and Pat
Riley and Magic Johnson
Gregg Popovich and Tim Duncan and over
and over it's going to happen so that he
has great talent at his disposal doesn't
take away from what a great coach
he is and I think what he does
exceptionally well is he allows them to
play with great offensive freedom and
confidence and at the moment of truth he
makes sure defensively that they are
absolutely locked in and I think in the
houston series you saw him play and ride
his starters and his top bench guys and
play everybody huge minutes because he
knew there was no margin of error in
that series and then he goes to Portland
series and he plays more people and by
distributes of minutes over a bigger
cross-section of players because in that
series he felt that was what was best
and so I'm interested to see what he
does here but there's no questioning
that he knows his team very well and he
does it in such a humble manner that I
have such respect for him and how he's
gone about all of the success in the NBA
from when he was a player to when he was
a broadcaster to a general manager and
now to a coach and then his colleague on
the other side I guess of the
of the court I mean you look at Nick
nurses resume Jeff and you could see I
mean a two-time British basketball
league champion coach a two-time NBA
d-league champion I mean the Oklahoma
storm the Iowa energy Rio Grande Valley
Vipers are some of the teams that he is
he is coached and now here he is after
getting the job when his predecessor
gets bounced despite winning coach of
the year or just weeks prior to it what
is going through Nick nurses mind do you
think right now Jeff well I think you
know because he was on the staff of
Toronto in previous years he realizes
it's hard to get where they got to
LeBron James moves from the Eastern
Conference to the Western Conference
Masai Ujiri the general manager of
Toronto makes a really tough decision
about moving on from Dwayne Casey and
then they change around their roster
with you know three new starters and
Danny Green Marcus all Kawhi Leonard and
so I think he you know Nick nurse is a
he's a very good coach he's done it at
many different levels along the way but
to backtrack just for a second
Dewayne Casey I feel for him like this
guy put so much into the Toronto
franchise and he took them from
mediocrity up until last year and he was
trying to fight through LeBron James
year after year and then right before
they make the big trades for a true star
in Kawhi Leonard and right before LeBron
James goes west
you know he's unceremoniously fired and
I just want to reiterate what a great
job he did in Toronto to set the table
for what Nick nurse Kawhi Leonard Marc
Gasol Kyle Lowry they're doing now I
think would be remiss if we didn't
acknowledge the impact
in case he had on this one yeah it is it
is obviously I guess raw deal could be
one way to look at it Jeff for for
Dwayne but he's there in Detroit it's
not as if he's staring at all four walls
right now but it's gonna have to be a
tough watch I would think the NBA Finals
for him if he sits down and sees it well
absolutely because you know you know how
delicate and fine the balance of winning
and losing is in the NBA and so here
Toronto was maybe losing in the second
round to Philly but then the ball
bounces four times and falls in and they
advance and then down to oh they make a
great great comeback and go on and now
they're here in the finals and they're
here in the finals with a totally
different team but took stronger team a
better team a deeper team and you're
like you said he bounced back great and
he's a terrific man and a terrific coach
but I don't think that makes it any
easier to watch this finals because he
knows he had a he in a big hand a big
part in getting them like I said before
from mediocrity to the edge of this or
precipice of this finals and yet he's
not able to take part in it it's got to
be difficult and then this is before I
let you go the last series of the year
obviously and then the one that's still
some July 1st riding on it I mean at
this whole regular playing season and
playoff playing season everybody is
looking over the dashboard at July 1 and
what it means and if Durant doesn't come
back and the Warriors win without him
what does that mean and does Kauai leave
if he does win it all and if he doesn't
does he still go to Los Angeles what do
you think is gonna wind up happening
based on this series and July 1 Jeff
well I think both all the free agents
particularly the the premiere free
agents who can sort of dictate where
they want to go they have an idea of
what they want to do I think all year
long but I do believe that circumstances
can change which can alter their initial
plan so for instance if Durant comes
back let's just say they're down to oh
they go back home he comes back they win
four out of the next five and win it and
he's Finals MVP again does that make him
more apt to stay or less apt to stay I
don't know his priority so I have no
idea but I think things that could
happen over the next 2 plus weeks can
definitely alter the plans that Durant
and Leonard have in their mind as of
today I certainly think that nothing is
totally locked in and I'd be remiss if I
didn't revisit it with you the issue
that we've discussed last couple times
you've been on this show that you
brought up during the broadcast and
regular-season about the Lakers having
all options on the table including
trading LeBron away with the latest
espn.com deep-dive article on if we got
a chance to read it maybe on the flight
or not at all about the current state of
the Lakers front office do you still
feel like that is maybe the best viable
option for the Lakers to move on Jeff my
whole point on that was I just think
when you're the Los Angeles Lakers and
you're six years out of the playoffs
everything has to be on the table and
one of the options was how do you get
the best possible roster put together
that's on the same within the same time
frame and so it would take an incredible
incredible offer to trade what's still
one of the premier players in the NBA
and LeBron James so I wouldn't think
that was best but I don't think it
should be totally put off the table
either I think what
are going to see is unlike many in the
media I think hiring a frank vogel is
going to work out exceptionally well I
think he is a outstanding coach that was
given when given a a true NBA roster but
she was an MBA in Indiana he absolutely
over achieved there in Orlando the
patience was low and the talent level
was low and their health was poor in his
two years there so I think he's going to
do a great job I think he and James are
going to do very well together I think
they will be in the playoffs next year
and I also think they're gonna make that
they're gonna have learn from some of
their roster mistakes this year the ball
needs to be put in James's hands he eats
shooting around and that's when he's
played is very best they need to put
stability on the floor character matters
in this league team this matters
selflessness matters it matters all
those things I think they came up short
with last year in their roster I think
they have the ability to correct those
mistakes as they go into this offseason
and I think they will and I think
they're going to be a top five seed in
the Western Conference next year Wow
Jeff I mean that's a Nostradamus right
there that's that's I said variate so
that's a rosy Patrick last year when
when James got hurt it's really not
going out on the limb when James got
hurt last year on Christmas Day they
were good they beat Golden State I think
he went out in the third quarter they
were in fourth place I mean the only
thing is they faltered but you know
during James's injury and then when
James came back they stayed a mess from
Christmas on but before that they were a
good a very good team and if James is
healthy and they put the right
components around him with a motivation
level that I think is going to be high I
think people are gloom and doom on the
Lakers right now and if I was a betting
person I would
the over because I think they're I think
they're gonna have a very good year Jeff
have a great finals look forward to
watching it really do thanks for the
call as always you got Jeff Van Gundy
here from Toronto on Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app